en conmoción aquí en niza después de
este nuevo atentado en la mañana de este
jueves atentado que tuvo lugar aquí en
la basílica de nuestra señora de la
asunción' en pleno centro de la ciudad
justo hasta momentos antes de que
comenzara el 'toque de queda' sobre las
nueve de la noche las personas
continuaron llegando aquí para unos
momentos de recogimiento frente a esta
iglesia depositar flores e incluso
encender velas hablamos con varios de
ellos que nos dijeron que todo esto
también les trae a memoria algunos de
esos amargos recuerdos después del
atentado terrorista de julio de 2016
escuchen lo que nos dijeron
estoy aquí y oro frente a esta basílica
porque la amo es mi casa
y acá yo vengo aquí todos los domingos y
porque hace 15 días asesinaron a samuel
y yo soy profesor jon existe dice
me sentí blanco de esto formó parte de
la educación nacional soy funcionario y
hoy es mi identidad católica la que ha
sido blanco católico que dice
más allá es mi identidad francesa la que
ha sido el objetivo
estamos en shock
como puede pasar esto en esta iglesia al
profesor de un colegio
como objeto muchas emociones fuertes que
salen y esto hay que utilizarlo para
avanzar y continuar demostrando que esta
barbarie nunca va a dividirnos ya
minutos de boxeo demostrar que estamos
todos unidos en este momento no sólo no
pero más allá de los homenajes un grupo
de militantes de extrema derecha vino
hasta frente a la catedral acompañados o
bajo custodia de la policía antimotines
ellos estuvieron aquí entonando la
marsellesa vestidos de negro y
observaron un minuto de silencio todo
esto deja muy en claro que una de las
tareas pendientes que tiene la sociedad
francesa es la unidad de esa misma que
hoy pedía el presidente de manuel marco
cuando estuvo visitando niza